how's it going gasps - beautiful I'm
here with Brad I'm so sorry we're
playing at one of your favorite games
this is my favorite game of all time all
time except that Brad is the unicorn guy
I'm glad to play - unicorn game but this
is your other game that you play on the
weekend I only play racing games kids
all right all right what happens if you
lose oh if we lose you get to eat a bang
we should have said that but then a band
booboo storm
guess we've been and been good a great
time
wow this is [ __ ] this is amazing this
is like I am right next to the speed oh
holy [ __ ] these cupcakes pretty bruised
how do you use the magic fun I don't
know I don't know your life is you just
you're shooting it right now I don't
know how are you shooting Fred the
cupcake I look at my screen it goes in
speech doesn't work yeah oh yeah that
one doesn't work and I can find no way I
told you I gave a didn't you give me a
[ __ ] dog controller you said it in
mind then I've got no time to be these
[ __ ] sick beams Oh brick yeah
absolutely free I've never been so
offended in my life uh yeah
a cushy one close her eyes
Oh share is it that uh they you know I
can't handle disgusting things by the
way that's puke or peach puke or page
Oh Oh what yeah is that popcorn
that's a popcorn or something like that
butter Mamie
yeah pretty good yeah buttered popcorn
yeah good [ __ ] how much now we saw
controls yeah
oh you look the alert put in this shield
me your friends okay no you'll see how
[ __ ] I used to try and play this odd
core Gran Turismo ripoff it was no Katie
that first place literally as soon as
you have the freaking oh my god come on
but I'm still doing it laughs you can't
do anything is horrible
this is [ __ ] yeah this is the best
game ever yeah and I love how incredibly
rigged the kids between us tournament
with these Dutch controllers we tried
but I outsmarted you by taking this
controller you outsmarted me though your
friends I'm second at least Swedish
heart you still got like seven or like
you didn't win by that much
no booger or juicy pear
Oh
cat burger I can tell they're pair but I
think was a booger really yeah it was
pretty good
how do they how do they get the taste of
booger I don't know what what do they I
don't know somewhere down there has to
go right we need to know what the taste
of a booger is no way actually
oh yeah well it I just want to give you
two seconds while I quickly just oh I've
got the controller which isn't a dud
we'll just swap then we'll swap that's
why it's fair yeah one on one off one on
the good control one on the back control
yeah it literally just means I eat one
you eat one I eat one you eat one that's
all I mean and then this is irrelevant
now you want me to just eat one now
all right this one could be anything
[ __ ] I don't know what is bang though
responded popcorn really a great - like
that it's this good way to you get sick
I don't did I just lose yeah oh no this
is gonna have a bad one yet this is
black skunk spray
no or licorice both bad both fat [ __ ]
it is awesome no my stomach's just on a
Chargers go my stomach time that
licorice not even Scott back on sperm
whatever it was a low-slung sperm
I'm seriously here is what liquor is
your stouts go guys oh man you making me
burp disgusting I'm trying to get it all
down with you this it um go up go up
nothing here okay is paused he still
tastes like a my [ __ ] smells oh my
mouth see my body this is it they want
to eat the pink one it smells so much
it's so bad bubblegum oh great good for
you here's what we're gonna do here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna get all
the black ones out alright I'll leave in
black fine
no we're gonna eat all one outside all
of the black ones in one go by
rock-paper-scissors just a good
old-fashioned PewDiePie channel
rock-paper-scissors the original game
that was ever made yeah this is for all
of them all of the black ones in there
in one go in your mouth Neha you've you
[ __ ] sick oh yeah right paper says it
oh yeah
Pocky I think follows now you know the
rule D I was bad at it [ __ ] that's right
I want to do it all in oh man can we
split him not be a good friend you love
since bread I'm the worst friend you've
ever had
hey god this is it like an acoustic
thinking about it
a kind of Catholic how are you gonna
drink your this drip
mmm that's pretty good ash yes clearing
out all of that skunky taste I had did
you want it yeah yeah now that really
does actually clear out the skunky taste
a string you want it look at that look
at that that is death right there one
day that will kill the whole human race
you'll put a tube in and it will felt
like every ten why we did this good game
yeah hello Kay and rock paper scissors
this is the weirdest video I've ever
been apart
welcome to the goodbye channel you tried
we're trying it's all my god follow the
trash you're the chef follow the trail